growing up in Missouri they would kind
of take us out into the woods they would
give you a map and they would give you a
compass and you had to find your way
home and without the compass you can't
even read the map that's what I'm here
to tell you the compass is the key a
[Music]
compass is most simply a piece of metal
that has been magnetized so that it will
turn towards the Earth's magnetic pole
the one that we all think of is the
pocket compass it looks like a watch
right you can hold it in your hand and
watch the little needle bounce around
until you find north magnetism is still
a pretty mysterious force to physicists
but what we do know for sure is that a
compass works because the earth is this
giant magnet and when you use a compass
you are in touch with the very center of
our planet where this kind of roiling
ball of molten iron is spinning around
and creating a magnetic field just like
a magnet you can play with on your
tabletop as a North Pole and a South
Pole and we use compasses to find our
way north because of that fact the
earliest known compass comes from about
200 BC in China they figured out that
some of the metal coming out of the
ground was naturally magnetic and so
they fashioned this magnetized metal
into this kind of ladle looking thing
put it on a brass plate and then it
would point north it seems to have been
primarily used to improve function so
they could figure out what was the best
way for energy to flow through their
living spaces sailors were probably the
early adopters of the more portable
versions of it because no matter where
the Sun was no matter what the condition
of the Stars were they would always be
able to kind of find North now much
later the Europeans are the ones who
innovate and come up with the compass
rose it essentially laid
what north south east and west looked
like and it also enabled you to kind of
create new directions like north west
south east what-have-you
for the first time they knew where they
were going that's kind of a big deal but
also I think it was part of this general
reinvigoration of European science and
you might know it as the Renaissance
lots of new tools were invented from the
telescope to the microscope Maps got
better because of compasses right
because then you start to understand
which direction is which you get a lot
more detailed and that just kind of
changes the human relationship to the
world the compass with a map is like a
superpower everything that we think of
as world history would not have taken
place without the compass the age of
exploration Magellan circumnavigating
the globe even the fact that we know it
is a globe the compass ends up getting
embedded in all these other tools
because it is such a functional object
so you might have it embedded in your
multi-tool you might have it embedded in
your phone the compass is everywhere
because it's literally how we find our
way across the face of the earth so you
can go off and explore and find out what
is over that next hill or that next
horizon but you can also reliably find
your way home
[Music]